صحفية روسية بارزة
تتعافى بعد تعرضها
لاعتداء وحشي في الشيشان، إيلينا مالاشينا، تعرضت
مراسلة لصحيفة مستقلة
لهجوم بينما كانت في طريقها لتغطية
حكم محكمة في غروزني، عاصمة الشيشان،
تقول إن مسلحين اختطفوها وقطعوا الطريق عن
المحامي الذي كان يسافر معها
كسر شعرها أصابعها وصبغها
باليوم الأخضر تصف كيف حدث ذلك،
أخرج المهاجمون سائق التاكسي
من السيارة ووضعوا رؤوسنا للأسفل
وحاولوا ربط يدي خلف
ظهري، يبدو أنهم طعنوا
ألكسندر نيموف لأن الدم بدأ
تدفقت من ساقه قطعوا
مسافة معينة وانفجرت السيارة
ولم يتمكنوا من تشغيلها مرة أخرى
فسحبونا إلى بعض الوادي
وبدأوا في ضربنا. وقد تعرضت
ماليزيا للتهديد بسبب
عملها في الشيشان من قبل عندما
كشفت عن الأمر.  حملة الهيئة على
الرجال المثليين قبل الهجوم، كانت
تغطي حكم المحكمة على ناشط في مجال حقوق الإنسان، وقد
أدان الكرملين الاعتداء قائلا إنه يتطلب
ردا جديا، ويحقق أمين المظالم في مجال حقوق الإنسان في روسيا